today i want to teach you exactly how i
took this
ordinary twin motion in port all the way
through
to this amazing twin motion export
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas
welcome back to the channel if you're
new here firstly thank you so much for
joining me
on this channel we talk about technology
and architecture
today i want to show you some of the
skills i've learned during my
professional career as an architect
i want to show you exactly how to use
twin motion and take it from a boring
basic render
to something incredible that you can
present to your client and even charge
for if you're really looking to
so let's turn around to these two
monitors and start creating
maybe something a little bit more dark
and moody than usual okay so because
we're creating something in twin motion
you don't need to see my face all day
we want to get nice dark and moody and
really create something special here
so we've got our twin motion export open
and it's
pretty boring pretty generic the house
has been designed it's
pretty much finished but the rest of it
isn't just looking how we want it to so
what we're going to do
is first go into that original image one
and start playing around with the actual
light
and surrounding settings so we click on
more we change the location because this
is in western australia we're going to
take it to perth but obviously you can
place that
absolutely anywhere you want personally
i like to see it in the morning as well
so we're going to set it to just during
sunrise and we're going to move that
north point around
to ensure we get the absolute best sun
location
the north point isn't pivotal in an
architectural render like this
because you're not showcasing how
actually look you're more so trying to
sell the building itself
okay so i think personally these
settings work really well 6 a.m in the
morning
december and a 30 degree north offset
it allows that sun to shine directly
onto the building and we're going to
start casting shadows across the
streetscape
as well a little bit later on so we've
set up our localization we want to move
to our weather
and start putting in some clouds you can
see that as we start moving it
through the seasons everything changes
ever so slightly personally i don't
think the water
down the bottom in twin motion is
perfect just yet so i avoid it
and i try to go to some early cloud
separation i like to keep it as neutral
as possible because that way when we
take it into
lightroom later on down the track we can
actually create all the colors and all
the seasons that we want by adjusting
those settings so now we have all our
lighting set up and it's already a
hundred times better than where it was
when we first imported it now what we
want to do is start adding some
materiality and some texture to this
individual render here
so twin motion has some great built-in
textures so you don't have to go and
download anything but there are many
resources out there
i talk about them in different videos
feel free to check them out if you want
to but we're going to start with the
actual landscaping
so we want to make sure that the grass
is all consistent we don't want to have
different grass types
so materials ground nature i like grass
too personally and i apply everywhere
now grass 2 looks all well and good but
you want to make it look
even better you want to make it look a
million dollars
so what you want to do is come up to
this context tab go vegetation paint
come back out to grass and flowers
and select the grass that you personally
like personally i don't mind grass 3 or
glass 1
grass 1 more so because i can edit it
how i want after in lightroom
so i'm going to choose long grass one
drag and drop it
click on that maximum 100 density
we can check in the settings if you want
to make it any bigger smaller dryness
etc but for the time being we'll keep it
exactly as it is
we'll go back into that click on the
grass one
select the paint brush and make a one
meter diameter
and all we have to do now is carefully
and slowly
paint the grass on and there we have it
all our grass is painted on for that
section of the house i didn't want to
bore you so i skipped the head
now it's important that the grass looks
consistent in this render throughout
you don't want to go and make this guy's
house beautiful lush green grass and
this poor bastard
terrible burnt grass so you want to
apply the same principle to all the
grass that you can see in the shot
if we go back to our image one we can
see that the grass on the left isn't
seen but everything on the right hand
side
is so what we have to do is continue
painting i'll skip ahead again and there
we go all the grass on the neighbouring
property is now completed
so if we were to come back to our
original image that we're looking to
export
you can see that the grass is completed
for some reason
it is not showing up because of all
these green little triangles
but be assured it is definitely there so
when you export it it will
be seen a lot better next we want to
focus on
the surrounding streetscape
unfortunately as important as the house
is
to make an architectural render look
good the street has to look
very realistic the surrounding bits and
pieces have to look realistic
if we wanted to go even further we
changed that white block of the house
to something that we didn't another
project but for the time being it's
absolutely fine
the straight poles again are very
important it gives you some sort of
context to where it might be
and in this particular case that
straight pole actually is there
so it's important that that client knows
they're going to see that big ugly
straight pole
and have absolutely no way around it
moving more onto the actual streetscape
and creating some more patterns and
textures along
this side of the road so what we want to
do is come back out into our materials
panel
and start changing the road and
everything around it
so we'll go to ground we'll go man-made
and we'll put asphalt 1
on the road asphalt 1 is a nice dark
black texture
and it looks really really good for the
driveway themselves we want to come back
out and go to concrete
and then use aggregate personally i
think
aggregate is just a great product for
driveways in architectural renders
and it creates something stunning what
you'll notice however is the aggregate
is quite small so we want to increase
the scale to about
where we see fit i think personally
exposed
at four looks really good the contrast
between the curbing and the road again
really important what we can do is
change that materiality of the curbing
as well
to a different form of concrete if we
want just to really break it up and give
it some texture so if we go to base
concrete 3 we can change that
and adjust it to however we see fit
maybe
2 scale in this one is the perfect
scenario
now the road looks great but the road is
just a black road there's nothing along
it there's nothing giving us detail and
we really want to emphasize
the reality of this render so if we come
back out to objects and go to decals we
start getting our
road style markers we want to use
as little as we can not to force our
computer to render too much
so we'll go back into our decals and
we'll use line marking one
for the side of the road if we push it
to 90 degrees
and originally place it just as close as
we can
to the side of the road somewhere about
here
we've tabbed through to be able to get
all our different options if you haven't
used twin motion before
and we know we don't see too much of
that but we do see
quite a bit of this road so we want to
hold shift click on the arrow
and drag it across just before you see
how it
overlaps and starts disappearing we want
to connect that
and make maybe 20 copies
and we have our first line we want to
quickly drag that while it's all
highlighted to the other side of the
road
perfectly just there and copy that
across
so now if we come back into our image we
see
that we have the first render the first
kerbing
a little bit of dirt there and i'm
probably going to readjust my render
to this spot here i think that looks a
lot better because you have the curb you
have the ground
and you have a lot more context one
thing we are missing is a center line
that is dashed so if we go back into our
decals panel
in the object section and select the
dashed line marking
rotate it nine degrees so it goes the
right way
that's roughly in the middle of the road
which is pretty good what we want to do
is the same thing we did a second ago so
hold shift drag it across till it lines
up perfectly
make 20 copies of it and click ok
so now we go back to our image to re
reevaluate
and again it's starting to look a lot
more realistic we have that line
separation
we have that center line we have the
natural grass we have
the different style of earth at the
bottom
we have to work on that a little bit but
we'll get to that in a second so now we
have our driveway over here and our
neighboring driveway
our neighboring driveway looks a little
bit sad so we're going to change the
materials and textures of that as well
it for some reason has a brick driveway
so we're going to continue to use the
brick driveway
we go into the brick utensils and we
pick a brick that we believe will look
good as a driveway
because this is great i'm probably going
to pick a gray brick to match it
and scale it up to about six i think
probably looks a bit more realistic so
now
again if we go back to our image to
compare what it's starting to look like
it's starting to build that character
and build that form it's starting to
look a lot more realistic
what we want to continue doing is now
emphasizing that streetscape
because the sun is beaming on this side
of the house
we want to try and landscape this side
of the property as much as possible
so we're going to start putting in some
very large trees to be able to do that
in this case there actually is very
large trees on this side of the road so
that's why this works out really well
and the trees in question are the west
red ciders so what we're going to do
is just multiply that tree across
the entire property as much as we can so
we're going to leave it maybe about 10
meter spacing and we're going to copy
about
50 of those trees i have no idea if
that's too many or not definitely too
many but
doesn't matter we're also going to focus
on the shrubs and
the base bushes down the bottom because
our original image
does capture a little bit of that bass
bush so we have that tree coming in
which is really nice and really pretty
but the natural ground looks a bit
average so we're going to focus on
just this little section of natural
ground and not worry about anything else
for the time being
because we're just focusing on this one
export if you're making multiple photos
then obviously
focus on the whole thing but for this
we're just doing it for that one little
section we want to go into our materials
and
change that natural ground so back into
ground back into nature
and we want to select something that we
believe looks a little bit better so
maybe some grassy ground
i don't like that personally how about
some forest ground excellent forest
ground looks a lot better
this tree looks a little bit fake but
that's okay
if we scale that forest ground up i
believe to about two will look
quite nice and start adding some base
bushes
around this entire section so
even now we aren't even looking at our
house we can see how that shadow's being
cast on the road that sun
is beckoning through the side and it's
starting to look really really nice
we want to use very generic base bushes
because obviously
this would be council property this
wouldn't be somebody's house so
the base bushes would actually just be
shrubbery they wouldn't be anything
fancy it would
genuinely just be very basic shrubs and
then we come back into our first render
well now we've got too many trees so
let's delete just the couple that we are
probably
having our camera angle from what we can
also do to make this road look a little
bit better before we start focusing on
that house there
is add some sewers and some drains so if
we come back into decals
like we were before for the road
markings at the bottom you can start
finding sewer grates
so personally i like to use them right
at the edge
close to some houses and make sure
they're coming over the line so we don't
want that line
to overlap in any way shape or form so
what we're going to have to do
unfortunately
is move that one line back away from the
sewer
and create a copy of this line just here
to give it that reality of it we're
going to replicate the same thing on the
other side
right where our image is so you can see
that sewer somewhere roughly here
and it gives it some really good context
and detail
so that is the wrong orientation in my
opinion we're going to drag it back
place it a little bit further out of
sight so it isn't obvious that it's fake
and take this one linear line and move
it out of the way
we're going to do the same thing with
the side and copy that one line by
holding shift and clicking on the
directional arrow
clicking ok if we go back to our image
now
we can see that sewers coming into
perspective if we want to take it
further i know i'd say the puddles look
a bit average but we can
put a small little puddle around that
sewer
maybe not that one there we go puddle
two
just so it looks like that water is
draining down into that sewer
so again it's about that context making
it real as much as possible
you don't want to be just stopping at
the fine details you really want to be
looking at
every detail so now we've mastered the
surrounding streetscape and we've
mastered what the entire property is
going to look like
it's time to focus on the actual
vegetation of that
property and any vehicles and movements
around the site
so what we're going to start with is a
basic vehicle
vehicles there's plenty to choose from
in twin motion which is great so we're
going to just pick a small little car
actually probably a big car because it
is a big house
maybe this range rover looking car
rotate that 90 degrees i want it to face
forward i don't like it being black
personally i think it blends in too much
the scene so i want it to be white in
this case
if we go back to our render scene
there's that beautiful range rover in
front of that multi-million dollar home
that power pole is looking a little bit
fake in my opinion
so we probably want to change the color
of that a little bit darker
they're dark green kind of burnt
timber here in australia so we really
want to make it
that darker color just naturally so it
disappears and it looks just like a
natural shadow
continuing with the landscaping we want
to add a couple trees here and there
so we can provide some sort of detail
into this house
potentially with a city object so if we
go back to objects
city planters there's some nice planters
in the city that you can utilize for big
spaces
so i like this one here personally for
these spaces
because it doubles as a bench so we just
have to tap our way through to
these black squares so we can adjust the
size of the planter
so we're going to make sure that planter
fits perfectly
in this space and there we have it our
first planter is completed with the
plant already in there
our second planter which needs to go
over here and is the wrong color
stone fine limestone we don't want that
we want some sort of rock
some sort of ground cover so we'll go
into nature and use the pebbles
to create that little feature that's
probably not actually going to be seen
from our render so it's not too big of a
deal
we want to go then into objects and back
into city and planters
i personally reckon the city planters
are better than
the actual living room planters in this
case
just because that's what i like i like
this one here
it looks good i don't like the tree in
question so you can double click
and start deleting that
terrible tree inside and replacing it
with whatever plant you can find so i'll
go back
and there we go we have our first cat
palm sitting in that beautiful pot
right in front of the house for some
reason this is meant to be a nice stone
wall
and it's shown as plywood so we just
want to double check
it is stone stacked it's just generated
the wrong material from archicad into
twin motion if we go into stones
and select a stacked stone that would
best reflect on this house
most likely i believe stone three would
fit perfectly
and it's going to be much larger stones
than that so
there we go three times scale that stone
wall is starting to take effect
the roof and the slab is meant to be
concrete in this situation so we're
going to select a concrete
that looks a little bit nice a little
bit textured but not too overpowering so
maybe
bare concrete too scaled up to an
absolute maximum
gives you a nice finish so if we look at
that concrete in more detail it looks
good
but it's very glossy so we're going to
bring that back down
perfect now we have our concrete slab
and
our concrete stairs at the very front
it's all the same texture in archicad so
it's linked it all together the windows
in my personal opinion
never transfer across correctly so you
want to go into glass and use reflective
glass
i think reflective glass allows it to be
reflecting the actual atmosphere
but also giving you an inside look as
well if you just go
clear glass it just it doesn't look good
it looks like it's missing
so think personally reflective glass
looks really nice
if we go back to our image we can start
adjusting that reflective glass how we
like it
so if we want it to be a little bit
darker a little bit black to give it
that nice sharp contrast from the
building
we can adjust that further in the color
settings
and i think it looks quite nice with a
darker black windows but not too dark
perfect i think that is a nice contrast
between the building and between the
glass
the last element is of course the wood
but i think the wood is a nice natural
color it just needs to be a little bit
darker so we use the eyedropper tool
and bring that wood color a little bit
further down without
completely ruining it so now we've
emphasized all of the elements of the
house
the landscaping and everything that is
in shot here today what we want to do is
focus a little bit on this driveway here
to make sure it's not so bare and bland
and then we're going to focus on the
rear property itself even though this is
a driveway
and it isn't landscaped we are going to
throw a couple small
flowers and a couple small bushes on the
side here
just to break it up we don't want
anything overpowering so we'll probably
go with a small little bush
and do what we did with the lines
and the trees and just replicate them
multiple times over
so now we see all those trees coming in
what we want to continue to do is add
some elements and some
life to this section so we'll probably
add another car just at the rear of this
property
so it doesn't look so bare and there we
go we have a small car at the back
it's probably a bigger car than it needs
to be a couple trees along the side
and i'm probably going to place one more
massive tree just on this side to really
tie that focus into the center of the
house so if we go back into our
vegetation landscaping and select a nice
big tree
just to really break it up that's
not that one probably that tree there
and we're going to make it significantly
larger and
move it further inland so now that tree
is just starting to frame the house
and we're starting to focus our eyes to
the masterpiece in the center
we also want to add a nice tree in the
background to hide this
white element of a house that we've set
up as a placeholder
so we'll select a small linear tree that
isn't too overpowering
potentially something like an english u
will be quite nice from that
vista so we'll just go back into our
image to make sure that isn't too
overpowering
and it is personally that tree is way
too overpowering so maybe we just make
it a little bit smaller
and push it a little bit further away
okay so now we've landscaped the side
we've landscaped
the rear property we've landscaped
everything we've made the road look nice
we've put some shadows casting over the
road so it isn't glaring with sun
we've made sure our house is looking
phenomenal now it's time to work on our
lighting
now looking at this house it's missing
the lighting elements it's missing some
architectural detail
so what i'd really like to do is create
one long strip light across the top slab
and one long strip light across the
bottom slab
we can do that in archicad very slim
simply and i'm not going to demonstrate
how to do that we'll just use a slab and
color code it differently
and i'm sure you guys already know how
to do that especially if you're able to
bring a house like this into twin motion
already
okay so now we've re-linked our twin
motion and archicad model and we've
created that nice
neon strip in the ceiling it obviously
isn't
correctly materialized so we're going to
go back into materials scroll to the
bottom
and select neon and then because we've
color-coded it correctly
we can just add neon one and there we go
we have a nice
multi-million dollar linear
architectural
lighting feature on this house and that
personally speaking
looks absolutely fantastic so now what
we have if we go back to our original
image
is a beautiful image ready for exporting
and
ready for color grading so the image so
far
looks really good it looks a million
dollars but it still
isn't perfect twin motion gives you some
great exports but unless you know how to
use
lightroom as well then unfortunately
this is
going to be the best you can produce out
of twin motion
now i say no lightroom what i'm about to
show you makes lightroom the simplest
process
ever so what we're going to do is just
quickly export this and jump into
lightroom
okay so we've imported our render into
lightroom
and if you've seen my presets video i'll
link it down below or you can
go straight to the presets down below
and grab these presets for yourself if
you know what you're doing
but i've already pre-installed all my
presets that i use for twin motion
exports specifically
if we go through them we'll see that it
adjusts the lighting based on the
seasons so we have summer external
internal winter external internal
autumn on all the works like i was
already saying this is a dark and moody
video so i think we're going to go for a
winter external vibe
and all of a sudden if we look at the
original image versus
the color graded image it is a
phenomenal difference
i think personally these shadows are
potentially a little bit
too dark so we can just bring up those
shadows a tiny little touch
and adjust that temperature just
slightly down to -10
so now it is a beautiful striking image
that looks a million dollars anyway
that's all from me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video
and i hope you were able to create
something just as beautiful as this
architectural render
if there's anything you need from me
please feel free to leave a comment down
below i happily answer
as many questions as i can and because
this video forms one of my 28 videos in
28 days for february of 2021
it would usually be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow